imagine the lego movie and Deadpool got
together and had a PG rated love child
well they kind of did
it's the Lego Batman movie yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers it's Jan here if you're a
Batman fan then you'll quite likely feel
you've died and gone to bat heaven when
you watch the latest entry in the lego
movie franchise with other fish to fry
hello han solo movie lego movie
directors Phil Lord and Christopher
Miller handed the directing reins for
this film over to Chris McKay who edited
and co-directed animation on the first
movie
McKay's production is a crazy colorful
irreverent ball of energy that races
through the Caped Crusader's many and
varied incarnations over the years while
weaving in a story of family and team
spirit that occasionally veers into
sentimentality never afraid to poke fun
at itself the bat Legacy movie cliches
or the movie business in general the
Lego Batman movie channels a spirit of
2014 super successful lego movie and
throws into the mix the kind of barrage
of meta gags and endless Easter eggs so
wickedly brought to life in Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool movie in fact you'll
need more than one viewing to catch all
of them and of course this being a
Batman movie there's plenty of what
you'd expect including tricked-out
vehicles and costumes an explosive
action will arnett returns as Batman
after debuting his own gravelly voice to
take on the character in the first lego
movie I loved Arness as Joe bin Arrested
Development and Devon in 30 rock and he
certainly puts his comedy chops to good
use here proving yet again that he was
the right choice for the part of a
preposterously pompous Dark Knight who's
in dire need of having his posturing
taken down a peg or two
as for the supporting cast Arnett's
Arrested Development co-star Michael
Cera gives an amusingly enthusiastic
performance as Batman fanboy and
sidekick Robin while ray Fiennes is
fantastic as Batman's Butler alfred
rosario Dawson puts in a nice turn as
Barbara Gordon jumping across to the
world of DC from the MCU where she's
usually found as nurse Claire temple in
Marvel's Netflix shows and as the voice
of the Joker Zach Galifianakis gives the
perfectly serviceable performance though
I doubt it'll stay with you in the way
say that Mark Hamill's does on top of
the main players as a ton of cameos
including loads of comic-book characters
as well as a varied bunch of individuals
from the wider world of movies and
literature and I'll have a video on that
soon as well as the movies cool
connections and Easter eggs now if
you're thinking this movie is
essentially one big
foreleg oh well in many ways you're not
wrong but there's certainly enough fun
substance and gorgeous visuals in the
film to mean it's more than just a
platter to serve up merchandise the one
thing I did find a little grating was
the amount of over-the-top product
placement for a certain smartphone if
you're looking for a loss of brick
building like in the first movie you
won't find it here which makes sense
because construction was a big part of
the actual story in the lego movie
whereas here it isn't and that didn't
bother me at all to be honest with you
oh and you won't find a song either with
the same level of earworm eNOS as
everything is awesome which in some ways
is no bad thing instead the soundtrack
uses 80's pop too often comical effect
and composer Lorne Balfe does a nice job
integrating some rather familiar
superhero themes into his score to sum
up the Lego Batman movie does a good job
continuing the entertaining franchise
kick started three years ago by Phil
Lord and Chris Miller it's fun often
funny silly and crammed full of cameos
connections and Easter eggs to the Caped
Crusader's world as well as a DC
Universe and beyond yes it does
sometimes indulge in sentimentality much
as its predecessor did but there's much
to enjoy in Chris McKay spin off and as
it's the first superhero movie housed in
a packed year of super flicks I'm glad
to say we're off to a good start
fingers crossed things carry on that way
now what did you think of the Lego
Batman movie and who are your favorite
DC superheroes and villains let me know
in the comments below
coming up I've got a Lego Batman Easter
egg video and videos on the DC TV shows
Supergirl arrow and the flash if you
enjoyed this video do share it and
subscribe for more movie reviews Easter
eggs and crazy movie and TV facts thanks
for watching and see you next time you
pka movie lovers